plaçons quatre serpents sur la façade de
l'hôtel de police désormais images du
passé le blason effacé discrètement
samedi après midi quelques heures après
la publication d'un article dans france
antilles
revenant sur une promesse d' emmanuel
macron de faire disparaître ce symbole
des criées de la période esclavagiste et
qui soit avait disparu des uniformes de
gendarme mais restait désespérément sur
le bâtiment de la rue victor sévère
alors qu'il a fait retirer toutes les
insignes des uniformes de la gendarmerie
pourquoi l'hôtel de police qui symbolise
un bâtiment administratif est il
toujours porter de c est un signe là le
syndicat sgp fo est très remonté je suis
un peu attristé qu'on soit obligé
d'avoir interpellé les médias pour
porter cette information à la population
donc il me paraissait plus simple que
des gens donc le préfet de la martinique
puisse simplement respecter la parole du
preneur et public y faire un v tout
signe distinctif de ces quatre serpents
sur tous les bâtiments publics
donc c'est vraiment dommage c'est fait
c'est tant mieux dur passe à autre chose
il faudra certainement être très
attentif pour se rendre compte de la
disparition du blason aux quatre
serpents que l'autorité préfectorale
signale avoir demandé bien avant le coup
de sang du syndicat dans le quotidien le
blason montrés du doigt et qui
alimentera toujours débats et
discussions je pense que c'est une bonne
chose en fait
mais d'un côté personnel ça me pousse à
faire plus de recherches pour savoir
exactement que représentait le drapeau
quatre serpents mais je pense
effectivement que c'est une bonne chose
parce que apparemment c'était
esclavagiste et c'est une très bonne
chose qu'ils ont cédé à la pression du
peuple
ton un peu son âme apprend parce que
l'esclavagé déjà passé déjà abolie et
pour passer à autre chose
il faudra pas oublier mais on peut
mettre de côté la halle en 2009 sans
oublier en oubliant met de côté on passe
à autre chose ont fait mieux
on sent reste un an plus généralement le
combat n'est pas terminé pour les
adversaires du blason quatre serpents ce
blason qui fait référence à la période
esclavagiste est encore présent dans
d'autres domaines comme le référencement
de notre île sur les plates formes
électroniques
un autre combat d'une autre ampleur